moving on for now whether you own your
home or rent your home you may be
looking for better ways to protect it
the list of potential threats is long
extreme weather break-ins even porch
Pirates some steel packages and they're
not only dangerous they can cost you a
lot of money Consumer Reports has put
out a new list of ideas ideas that they
hope will help you out on all this
testers have identified the very best
protection devices security systems
video doorbells indoor security cameras
and even sturdier and more secure door
locks if you don't want all that
technology around you want to do it the
old-fashioned way Consumer Reports
Deputy editor Brian Vines is here Brian
this is a well-timed segment because
just last night 11 30 we heard a noise
in the house got the elbow in bed how to
get up baseball bat over the shoulders
tighty white is on below walking through
to every room we've got to look
everywhere give the report when you get
back home if we had a better security
system maybe I wouldn't have to get out
of bed welcome to but you have a
security system you do yeah yeah Welcome
to Brooklyn
not for nothing but it's just the thing
but security systems can be your eyes
and ears so that 11 30 nudge can resolve
with a quick Scroll of the smartphone
but also uh you know just being better
aware so where do people begin
and how hard is it it is not very hard
one of the things that I suggest is
beginning with your most risk of risk
averse friends if you have that sort of
eye to say oh this is potential problem
this is a potential potential problem
yeah but we ranked many security systems
and for those who have a DIY Spirit okay
and want to avoid that about a dollar
per square foot that it costs to install
a professional system right there are
some very good do-it-yourself systems
and we rank them that uh security system
from SimpliSafe for about 165 dollars
the essentials kit offers a great level
of protection and these things typically
have that big brain console right that
uh is the sort of Mothership of the
whole thing and comes with some sensors
for your windows as well as motion
detectors and a camera so you can set it
up yourself so you think it's easy to
install Brian I personally own this
system and it was easy to set up there's
some trial and error I like to say it's
Choose Your Own Adventure yeah you can
put it in this corner make sure that the
motion sensor has a very wide field so
Corners are great to get the widest
Fields also camera setup when you're
setting up the camera put it in a place
and test it throughout the day when the
sun comes in and is it going to wash out
part that you would like to see secure
your visual so live with your system and
make it custom it's a very democratized
way of looking at security so as far as
where to put the camera you're saying
just play around with it a little bit
before you have a permanent location
that's the great thing because nothing
is settled until you settle it so you
get the base system the keypad but the
sensors for motion can go anywhere
they're portable so you can put them we
recommend near a point of entry of
course the stairs in a room where you
keep your Treasures so where your
valuables are but it is a system that
lives with you and it can adapt to you
so is it what you're describing sounds
portable I'm from that you the door
opens it talks to me I do the keypad
it's wired to something I want to make
it very difficult for anybody who was
trying to get in you're saying that the
the portable ones the DIY ones are just
as effective they can be just as
effective and you can carry it around
with you and you know we're we're a very
much a mobile people on the move right
now and if you want something that's
portable you can take it with you
instead of investing that a dollar a
square foot in your two thousand square
foot house two thousand bucks for a
system that you leave behind when you
move yeah so you can take 462 dollars
for the Simply Safe system that makes
sense you can take it with you and work
it in an apartment or in a dorm or
wherever you may be so warm that's an
advantage it can also be costly to lose
packages that get delivered and they get
left outside your door so you might want
a doorbell camera to at least see who's
yeah what do you recommend on that front
we have three that are recommended uh
and we based it on the image quality on
how quickly the system alerts your
smartphone when uh someone is there and
also their privacy uh ratings so the top
three that we're recommending are
represented here from Rings video three
doorbell to the Simply Safe to the TP
Link now one thing that I love is this
price spread right the 100 199 ring
doorbell happens to be Amazon's number
one seller okay and it's also battery
powered so once again that portability
Factor you don't have to hardwire it you
can hardwire it but it's not uh
necessary it has a battery pack and
that's 199 but available right now at
Target for 150 bucks so right now news
you can use those are the ones you can
talk through right yeah whoever's on
your porch yeah you can say what do you
have any specific set of words somebody
should say
[Laughter]
I guess we're gonna have to put the the
low-tech lock Solutions on our website
because we're running at we're running
low on time uh also home insurance as
well and Gail just to close things out
yes I have a professionally installed
security system being like go check that
out and then you know always Maya
Angelou has a great story she didn't
have a security system but she did have
a weapon she heard somebody coming up
the stairs and she said come in is this
the day you were choosing to die
I love that story